I'm Trevor Phillips this is Common
Ground where each week we look for
agreement on a hot button issue dividing
the nation tonight
I said before that Britain can survive
outside the European Union and indeed
that we could find a way
as we leave the European Union we will
Forge a forge a Bowl's new positive role
for ourselves in the world
and we will make Britain a country that
works not for a privileged few but for
every one of us do not underestimate
this country do not underestimate our
powers of organization and our
determination because we know the
enormous strengths of this economy we
have huge reserves of talent of energy
and determination I am confident that
together we can ride out the storm we
can rebuild our economy building an
economy that Embraces the opportunities
of brexit I voted for brexit I believe
in brexit and I know that brexit can
deliver and is already delivering
enormous benefits and opportunities for
the country we have to make brexit work
the deal this government has got us is
not working well it's holding business
back it's holding growth back
brexit was and is brexit but it's
certainly not done some believe that's
because it was always doomed to fail
others because we really haven't put our
backs into making Global Britain a
reality
but on both sides of the Great Divide
there are conflicting emotions even some
of those who voted to leave the EU now
show signs of biased remorse according
to the latest polls they worry that the
benefits are outweighed by the
disadvantages of being outside the block
or to blame post-covered Ukraine and the
energy crisis
on the other hand some who maintain that
brexit was a mistake think each one
we'll have to live with the best we can
do is say these are euro pragmatists is
build better relations with our
neighbors at a time of economic turmoil
but has leaving the EU made that
economic pain worse our choice tonight
which gear for brexit reverse full steam
ahead or as so often in British life can
we find a happy medium in the next 30
minutes we go in search of common ground
[Music]
with me tonight the former Chancellor
Lord Kenneth Clarke Richard Tice the
veteran brexit campaigner who now leads
the reform UK party and Jill Rutter
senior research fellow at the UK in a
changing Europe Think Tank
I think we can all agree that the
prospect of uh return to June the 22nd
2016 is pretty much zero unless somebody
wants to violently disagree but before
we discuss whether we need to revisit
brexit in any way or talk about how we
complete the deal let's first see if we
can agree on what
um part of our economic pain is down to
brexit and what's down to other reasons
um Ken cost of living crisis is it all
about brexit
no it's not all about brexit uh I mean
there's a global recession and uh it's
obviously the combination of two things
certainly uh kovid and the huge
disruption that's caused to supply
chains throughout the world and it also
uh it's it's caused by uh the Ukraine
war in particular and the huge surge in
Energy prices and other prices
but I think the reason the British are
doing worse
than any other major country because we
have a self-inflicted third problem on
our hand which is brexit
and I think brexit is doing damage to
the way we're doing it at the moment I'm
again I agree with you entirely there's
no point in thinking it's ever going to
be reopened the referendum's referendum
that's it but we went for a hard brexit
not a soft brexit
the result is that it is damaging our
economy our trade with our most
important trading partner has collapsed
it's weakened our attractiveness to
investors throughout the world because
we're no longer what we tried to be the
most business friendly place to invest
to get into the huge rich single Market
of Europe and so we have put on top of
kovid and the war we and and that were
our problems as well and we put on top
of that brexit and we're not making a
very good job of sorting out how to live
with it because the deal we've got is
appalling all right Richard Tice um we
will come to the specific issue of the
effect of brexit in a moment but do you
agree with Ken Clark that cost of living
crisis and the other issues that we are
currently facing under this channel for
that Chancellor are to some extent uh
the result of other factors including
the ones he's talked about the first two
factors that can quite rightly
identified is the cost of living crisis
the cost of energy but we've also got
the fact that we've now got the highest
taxation we've had since the second
world war when Ken was an excellent
Chancellor in the 1990s our total tax
tape was about 29 it's now about 37
percent when he was Chancellor our real
wage growth because we didn't have
freedom of movement of low-skilled
unlimited immigration was 2.8 per annum
for the last decade it's been zero so
we've had a shocking level of
productivity in the last decade we've
had our lowest growth decades since the
second world war and that's led to the
situation and the thing is that this
Tory government has elected actually
technically we've left the European
Union but we haven't taken advantage we
haven't cut taxes we haven't cut
unnecessary regulation we haven't
controlled immigration to get higher
wage growth for the lowest paid so at
the moment we're sort of in a we're in a
limbo the economy is in bad shape it's
actually not broken and with a source of
recovery plan that reform UK put forward
we could actually restore and grow our
economy fast really very quickly Jill
how much um I'm not going to ask you
about a percentage on it but how much
would you say the problems that we've
been facing through that and the various
Maxi mini in between budgets have tried
to solve are to do specifically with
brexit how much might be long-term
long-running problems of productivity
The Hangover 2008 and so on so there's
undoubtedly been a long run problem
um you can go back to 2008 that's when
the UK's productivity problem started
what people throughout the decade before
the brexit referendum were referring to
as the productivity puzzle why had UK
productivity suddenly gone down so you
can't attribute that to brexit
um but I think you can say that
economists before the referendum were
nearly universally predicting that if
you put up trade barriers to trading
with your biggest trade partner at least
in the short run you are going to take
some sort of economic hit you make
yourself less attractive for business
investment and Richie sunac when he was
Chancellor told the treasury select
committee back in March that business
investment had been very low 2016 to
2020 because it wasn't clear what the
UK's relationship would be with the
e-user that has taken a hit Sterling has
taken a hit that puts up prices we saw
that very quickly after the referendum
and we've seen some inflation in food
prices uh I think people estimated that
brexit might have manage about six
percent to food prices that isn't
something that the economies that didn't
brexit to the rest of the U EU was
suffering from but if you look at cost
of living now inflation in Germany is
pretty high inflation you know in the US
is quite high so that is not a uniquely
British problem so I think it's right to
attribute that to a variety of other
things but to add to Ken's list of of
brexit whether it's a problem or not is
a different issue but undoubtedly there
are sectors that had come to depend
on recruitment of cheap labor largely
from the EU which are struggling to
adjust to the absence of that labor
because you know okay well we start with
a disappointing level of agreement that
actually there is a there is a series of
different uh issues here I want to talk
really about the extent to which brexit
can be a principal cause or not I'm
going to come back to your point by the
way Richard about migration a little
later if we made
um uh can load productivity has dogged
the UK I mean Jill said from 2008 but
actually I think it was an issue even in
your time uh as well
we we we we we had decent growth we we
thought our normal level of growth was
two and a half percent
uh we we had uh low and we exceeded it
we're over three percent sometimes but
then I used to raise interest rates
because I didn't have a an independent
bank I argued with any George but I I
used to have a question
and uh so we we get two and a half
percent plus we were achieving by way of
growth uh we got inflation down to a two
percent Target that we'd set ourselves
and we made sure we kept it there we
adjusted fiscal policy accordingly
that's what's guarded my garden my
policy I wasn't I did not go in for any
Mad Dash for growth by just cutting
taxes we're talking about history at the
moment if you're referring to anything
well I was trying to avoid contemporary
events yes I think that theory should
have been banged on the head for all
time uh recently with taxes in public
spending were set in order to make it
the public finances sound and together
with monetary policy keep inflation as
near to our Target of two percent as we
could and but that's how we were going
then and it is and it boomed even more
in the early 2000s because we kept
having economic booms which the top
wasn't taken off quite as he should have
been as it used to be okay and by 2008
that crashed together but Ken's actually
reinforced and agreed with the very
Point I've just made which was that
wonderfully growth was averaging in
Ken's tenure two and a half percent a
year give or take we're now lucky we're
now lucky to get to one and a half
percent and the reason is because you
didn't have to because you've done such
a great job in getting tax taked down to
less than 30 percent and I repeat it's
now 30 and heading north and that is a
massive constraint on productivity on
growth on the desire of people and
businesses to invest in the UK and so
it's quite right to go for low taxes but
you've got to cut unnecessary regulation
and of course got to do it in a funded
way
she failed to do what I was able to do
who was get Britain to recake the
benefits out of our creation because we
LED creating a single Market out of the
single Market we suddenly had these
great opportunities open to us because
we were in the biggest Board of free
practically free trade regret in the
world and of course we were working on
moving towards a single currency to take
away another obstacle effect
well we couldn't we couldn't get the
fiscal rules and the others right I
wouldn't have joined unless we could
have got Ken rules working in in the
Glorious Clark as Chancellor era of
which we've all been speaking you did
have we had our moments
you had all the weapons at your disposal
you were controlled both a fiscal policy
tax and all of that and monetary policy
and in the sense actually Richard's
point is that joining the EU as the
Greeks for example discovered took those
hours away from you well because you did
have to follow fiscal I mean if you've
never gone to a scene I would I never
reached a stage where I thought we
should conjoin as a state of preparation
but a large part about right Jill who
used to come to my press secretary we
spent a large part in discussions about
trying to get the rules The single
currency was took years and one of the
things that was clear was you did need
some common understanding not totaled by
anything it's amongst all the member
states on sensible fiscal policy and the
monetary policy needed to be in the
hands of an independent bank the
European Central Bank the Greeks should
never I mean if I want me to criticize
EU policy after we'd left the Greeks
should never have been led into The
single currency when they were let in it
was for political reasons and I'd be
quite right to say they were shocked to
discover that they're going to be in
serious trouble if they didn't just stop
trying to borrow their way out of
trouble all the time Dill well I think
um on The single currency you know I'm
not sure the UK would ever have gone
into the single currents that was one of
the sort of debates so we had back when
uh when Ken Clark was Chancellor about
keeping keeping the option open on the
independent Central Bank clearly the
moment Gordon Brown as Chancellor stood
up and announced that he was making the
Central Bank Independence you know
extending what we then termed the Ken
and Eddie show to actually giving full
Independence rather than just
transparency and then Governor Eddie
George Eddie George yeah yeah when we
moved on to full Independence there was
immediately a sort of discount on UK
interest rates because they perceived
that the UK was less risky than it had
been had been then but I think the
really interesting question now and I
think this comes to what what Richard
was saying and maybe going back to this
review is you know Liz trust and
quasi-quarting did try to go straight
for cutting taxes but they didn't have
the other pillars of their new policy in
place and so it was extremely
unconvincing that it would work they
didn't set out their plans for radical
deregulation nor give any indication
that they could actually get that
through Parliament nor did they set out
plans to rein back the state and cut
spending which is now dominated by
Health spending they didn't show that
they had feasible plans they could get
through Parliament to do that now if
they'd wanted to succeed The Logical way
of doing it would be to spend political
Capital I'm showing you actually can
deregulate and change I I don't I don't
want to go over that because we've
discussed um that painful episode on on
this program and others on Sky I'd like
to talk a bit more about Richard's point
of course one of the other elements uh
in this whole equation and you're all
this is this is worrying you're all sort
of agreeing that in fact brexit had a
big part but it's not it's part of a uh
I'm not agreeing that okay well a
significant a meaningful part but it's
part of a wider set of things the point
that you're making uh Richard which is
about uh migration which you think is an
important issue um the the CBI has been
saying the last couple of days and we
heard
um the lead of the opposition talking
about it uh today that CBI is being
saying employers are crying out for
people to do jobs uh more than a million
EU citizens weren't home after brexit uh
did brexit not shoot us in the foot and
actually provide the single biggest
option to growth now it's exactly the
opposite why do we have the lowest
growth decade since the second world war
in the last decade the answer is because
we've had no real wage growth because we
had unlimited freedom of movement and
that was an absolutely massive Factor
what's happening now is you've got the
big multinationals saying we want more
cheap low-skilled immigration when when
Ken was Chancellor the reason you had
real wage growth was because you
couldn't just turn the tap on for cheap
labor so if businesses couldn't afford
the the labor they invested in Capital
Equipment that's how economics has
always historically worked if you can't
afford the labor you invest in Capital
Equipment we've got a shocking
investment uh track record in the last
20 years because of the available of
cheap low skilled labor actually secure
staff has touched on it today we're now
all finally talking about the importance
of growth the way you get growth is you
improve productive we haven't got a
People shortage in this country we've
tragically got 5.3 million but there's
no no bigger with you Trevor there are
5.3 million people on out of work
benefits and there's a reason why
someone like a big retailer complaining
last week they couldn't get anybody to
work in their warehouses because they're
offering 20 less than one of their
neighboring competitors so they just
want to reach for the cheap labor tiller
what about actually offering a proper
National living wage and meeting your
competitors Ken Clark this is a really
interesting testing a picture of your
era because not only do you control
fiscal policy you also control monetary
policy but according to Richard you're
also able to close the tap on migration
um
I I didn't know that you were so
immensely powerful but is that an issue
now do you think it is now uh like I
remember when freedom of movement came
in I think it may have come in in mind
those post ACC session 2004-5 was really
the that was the war well I think what
changed it guys I I kind of disappoint
you again I do agree with some of what
Richard said what happened when the EU
enlarged to take in Eastern European
countries rather more quickly than I I
would have argued I argued against
letting Croatia and I was wrong about
Croatia I I was much more our foreign
office wanted to let them all in and I
was wanting to slow down as Chancellor
the the the the the the anyway what
happened was suddenly a flood of cheap
labor became available to us but more
importantly if
freedom of movement on balance is a good
thing it's essential in a free market if
you've got a totally free market as we
created but the the uh because you get
skilled people going backs and forwards
freely and people can enjoy careers
partly in their own country partly when
they're younger going abroad and and
lots of good people came here people
would be on there our employers over the
years have rather slipped into
not wanting to train the skilled people
that they're short of exactly and
they're used to getting them to come
straight from Romania I mean our health
service is the one that most members of
the public we're most familiar with the
number of immigrants workers at every
level of skill in the Health Service is
a terribly High proportion of the entire
Workforce that's why what we should be
doing now for our own domestic reasons
as we are never going to go back into
freedom of movement you can don't have
to worry about that I don't think can't
see that ever happening then it is
actually going for really seriously for
skills training and retraining
throughout people's lives stop
neglecting further education it's got no
money at all in the from the present
government when they were giving more
money to schools recently stopped
running down your other education and
provide incentives like The Apprentice
Levy but other incentives and
disincentives to make employers
train their own skills which they always
use you you could be reading from the
speech made today by the leader I agree
I I I've not he hasn't converted me to
support the labor party but I agreed
entirely yes what kierstama said on the
subject but seriously Trevor we've got
one and a half million more people on
out of work benefits than pre-covered
and that is a tragedy of wasted talent
and we have to as a nation support help
and training get these people back into
work and then we haven't got a labor
shortage Jill um let's talk let's talk
about what we might do and let's start
with this issue of uh the the labor
shortage
in order to at the moment we don't seem
to have uh reduced the number of uh
migrants coming to the countries and net
migration is still running at something
like a quarter of a million but now
they're coming from somewhere different
they're coming from India and they're
coming from China uh in a sense brexit
produced exactly the reverse of what I
think a lot of people thought it should
do and Richard's point is that that's
because it's not really being
implemented
do you think that we actually have a
choice here
about uh what we do on the migration
front so it is quite interesting that
we've in a sense delivered on migration
I mean people ask about delivering sort
of brexit we have moved to give visas to
people who have uh higher skills that's
what the new migration regime does
um through the sort of points-based
scheme we now have people coming in into
it so I.T professionals people using the
health Visa because we don't have enough
of our own Workforce there the real sort
of dialogue of the deaf in a sense
between business and government at the
moment is about people at the lower end
so either low-skilled or low paid people
where business obviously that has been
used to having access to low-paid people
doesn't particularly want to change its
business model for some it may mean
investing for others that have just been
going out of business uh because you
know it's not clear you can automate
restaurants or coffee bars in a sort of
hugely you know valuable way and there's
quite a lot of the people who depended
retail and hospitality is one of the
sectors so very badly hit farming
negotiates every year with defra and the
home office does a bit of a dance about
what's called the seasonal agricultural
worker scheme are they allowed to you
know offer visas it was clear actually
that Eastern Europeans were stopping
coming even before brexit because
actually the you know growth of the
Eastern European economy is the closing
of that Gap meant I think the migration
advisory committee some of them got
richer people also going back so it's
actually you know we weren't going to
get that access anymore Anyway Richard
this is a bit of a problem for for your
position isn't it because
you say that actually we should train
people up but actually the gaps where we
have uh which we have a shortage are in
places for example Hospitality short 174
000 social care uh low paid minimum wage
jobs probably a bit more than that
actually uh agriculture of course is
seasonal but
we the issue of shorted labor shortages
in many of these uh sectors is not
really one about training our people it
is simply haven't got enough bodies it's
not you've absolutely hit it on the head
you've said social care is low paid
that's a disgrace it's a vital vital
industry we shouldn't be just naturally
assuming that they should be lowly paid
I go back to the age-old way that
economies work if you can't find the
labor you pay more and either the labor
arrives or you invest in Capital
Equipment right so for example why
haven't we invested in the combine
harvester for apple picking or for
strawberry picking or for great picking
why because you could have cheap
overseas low-skilled labor so people
didn't invest this changes it businesses
have to invest or they will suffer
that's what competition is all about you
were a champion of wage restraint uh as
Chancellor and what what would you say
about what Richard just said sound to me
like you'd be on the opposite side to
you well because I I can remember
you keep making me go back into my past
which I usually it's such an interesting
part well the 70s and 80s when we had
wages and prices chasing each other
which is what the bank of England's got
to avoid us returning to that's a very
important priority at the moment uh so
to we had power more powerful trade
unionism we had very militant trade
unionism in those days uh and we're
going to have a winter of discontent
this winter but we don't want to go back
to that at the bank of England's got to
its stuff
going back to what you say you
wage increases have got to be based on
productivity improvements that actually
is what increases everybody's success in
a successful economy
and it's not the idea that all you do is
just put wages up and everything sorts
itself out is a recipe for returning to
the 1970s and hyperinflation the social
care trying to remember the name of this
program uh social care I actually do
again agree with quite a bit that's an
area that's going to need more public
spending and investment to make sure
that the pay and the training and the
career prospects of the people who work
in it are actually elevated to the
status they deserve it's one of the
reasons why we're never going to react
to low taxation again of the kind I was
used to we're not going to have the
small state that's a right-wing illusion
because we're all growing older and
we're getting more demanding and the
National Health Service and social care
are amongst other things are going to
require a much higher level of public
spending than I would have accepted let
me just put one last point because we've
got about a minute or so
um Richard one thing that we haven't
discussed is a trading relationship
um there are many people I know Kenneth
one and I suspects also of this view
that so that the the situation that we
now have is one that it's inhibiting
growth because we have an inhibited
trading relationship with the EU let's
forget about the the promise of global
Britain and all that for a moment but do
you accept that there is a problem obr
says maybe four percent of GDP
I don't accept what the obr says because
it's got a woeful track record or almost
everything it's forecast in the last two
or three years and I don't accept that
but look there's no question that uh in
a sense the eu's tried to punish us for
having the temerity to leave but let's
remember trade with Europe is a it's a
minority really quite a small part of
our overall economy and what Ken's
rightly said is you've got to focus on
investment and productivity and growth
but you only get that by having lower
taxes sensible regulations when Ken was
in charge we didn't have the burden of
another 20 years of Daft EU regulations
but what this government's failed to do
is to start to reduce those and that has
a real impact the impact of hindering
regulations is a massive impediment to
growth for businesses the policy of the
president government forced upon it by
its rather fanatic right-wing element
that it's now got uh rather too many of
on the back benches is to have seek free
trade agreements with the entire Globe
including pursuing free trade agreements
with the United States and India neither
of which are actually very interested
okay trade agreement with this but to
keep putting more trade barriers between
ourselves and our biggest single Market
uh obviously easiest trading partner
okay our next door neighbors one of the
wealthiest economic power blocks in the
world all right well look um it is my
duty at the end of these programs to try
to sum up and what I should be saying at
this point as I usually do is that I
have failed to find Common Ground
actually my failure this week has been
even bigger that actually the three of
you rather agree on the important things
that actually there are series of
courses of which brexit is one you may
not agree on exactly how big a
contribution uh it's it's made that you
all agree that uh we could do something
better now uh you rather all agree on
the issue of uh migration and economy I
think Ken surprisingly to me you're
slightly key uh Keener on limitations
than I thought you would be but what you
also all agree common ground is that Ken
Clark was just a genius and Chancellor
and uh wouldn't it be wonderful if we
went back to those days so don't debate
that any further okay I want to say
thank you to all my three guests
foreign
[Music]